في صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز حذر تقرير من
مخاطر عمليه عسكريه واسعه النطاق في رفح
يستند التقرير الى صور للاقمار الصناعيه
تظهر كيف غيرت الاعداد الكبيره من
النازحين شكل المدينه التي تعتزم اسرائيل
مهاجمتها ويشير التقرير الى ان مواقع في
رفح تعرضت للقصف بالفعل والخيارات قليله
امام المحاصرين
فيها يرى مقال في صحيفتها ارتس ان اصرار
نتنياهو على محاربه حماس حتى تحقيق نصر
كامل مجرد وهم يستنتج المقال من تصريحات
نتنياهو الاخيره انه وقع في العديد من
التناقضات منها حديثه عن تدمير الانفاق
رغم حقيقه انه هدف صعب المنال وعمليه
عسكريه في رفح مع انها غايه في التعقيد
بالاضافه الى اجاباته الغامضه على
التساؤلات حول مستقبل غزه وتهديد حزب الله
في صحيفه لوموند نجد ان شبكه انفاق حماس
لا تزال سليمه رغم القصف الاسرائيلي
المكثف منذ بدايه الحرب تنقل الصحيفه عن
مصدر عسكري فرنسي قوله ان تدمير انفاق
بالشكل الذي تبدو عليه في غزه يكاد يكون
محاله لافتا الى فشل انواع مختلفه من
القنابل في الوصول اليها وفشل خطط اغراقها
بالمياه صحيفه الاندبندنت
الضوء على رساله وجهتها منظمه اطباء بلا
حدود الى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني تقول
فيها ان هناك ادله متزايده على ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يستهدف الصحفيين دا المنظمه
ذكرت انها قدمت شكوي لمحكمه الجنايات
الدوليه بشان جرائم ضد الصحفيين في الشرق
الاوسط منذ السابع من اكتوبر وشددت على
ضروره الضغط على اسرائيل للسماح بتوثيق
عملياتها
العسكريه
في الو سري جورنال نقرا بان قتل قائد بارز
في كتائب حزب الله بغاره جويه في العراق
يزيد من مطالبات طرد قوات التحالف وفق
الصحيفه الضربه اضافت المزيد من التوتر
بين بغداد وواشنطن وكثفت الضغوط الشعبيه
والسياسيه على الحكومه العراقيه في اتجاه
انسحاب قوات التحالف بقياده الولايات
المتحده من الاراضي
العراقيه